and now in fight our first speaker in a
deal who has given us a title there's
plenty of room at the bottom of the
river modeling pollution from the
nanotech revolution welcome Amy thank
you in 1959 Nobel prize-winning
physicist Richard Feynman gave a
groundbreaking talk titled there's
plenty of room at the bottom in which he
challenged side this the discoverer
means of manipulating matter at the size
scale of individual atoms and offered
one thousand dollars to the first person
who could fit the entire text of the
Encyclopedia Britannica on the head of a
pin this prize was claimed by calm
Newman in 1985 today nanotechnology has
become a multi-billion dollar enterprise
backed by such industry giants as
samsung nokia and hewlett-packard
everyone in this room uses
nanotechnology every day it's in your
cell phones your laptops and your cars
importantly however it may also be in
your socks and shampoos your makeup and
sunscreen and your food these low-tech
uses of nanotechnology involve the use
of metal or metal oxide nanoparticles
and globally we now produce up to
300,000 metric tons of these tiny
particles each year the problem is that
sixty to ninety percent of what we
produce is eventually going to end up in
the environment and some of the metals
commonly found in nano particles such as
silver copper and zinc are some of the
oldest known environmental pollutants
for my first project is a PhD student I
modeled the complex chemical
transformations that one particular
nanoparticle nano silver undergoes in
the lake beds and riverbeds where it
accumulates once it escapes into the
environment this work revealed that nano
silver will react with naturally
occurring sulfur-containing compounds in
a way that actually reduces its toxicity
over time unfortunately this process
also increases the particles lifetime
leading to its persistence and
accumulation this model provided
valuable insights but it fails to
capture the big picture to bridge this
gap I'm currently developing a watershed
scale model in collaboration with the US
Environmental Protection Agency this
work combines data from elevation maps
agricultural surveys meteorological
records and more to describe water
sediment and nanoparticle transport
throughout an entire watershed this
model serves both the theoretical and
practical purpose
on theoretical side it acts as a proof
of concept showing us that we can use
traditional modeling frameworks to model
nanoparticles even though this new class
of pollutants doesn't always behave like
conventional pollutants on the practical
side it allows us to answer several key
questions will no no particle production
now or in the future lead to
environmental concentrations of metals
that exceed toxicity thresholds or
regulatory limits what are the major
sources of nanoparticles in the
environment and finally how can we most
effectively manage nanoparticle risk by
asking these questions early and often
we aim to inform industry and government
decision making for the safe and
responsible adoption of this promising
new technology thank you thank you Amy